[Music]
sorry I have to make another
withdrawal
[Music]
don't turn around I can help you keep
taking out money that minivan to my left
that yours yes just for clarity you've
been carjacked
right my child is in the back SE
gun yes stay here this won't take
long come
on your mom better hurry the [__] up kid
or this is going to go bad for both of
[Music]
you
hi want to see your mom it's okay it's
okay it's okay I'm here I'm
here that guy will be out for a while go
in the bank call the cops give him
these guns in the car wait who are you
someone who prefers not getting
[Music]
involved
you've been carjacked right don't turn
around this won't take
long wait who are you someone who
prefers not getting
involved you refer to the special
investigators as your team your soldiers
even your friends you do not mess with
this
investigator and now they're all in
[Music]
trouble they were tortured they dumped
them from a helicopter and they're
coming after
us
good damn reer when we were kids we just
wrote our names in it why'd you got to
hit him so
high I don't hit soft
what are our
directives we prepared we investigate we
put back Us in jail what do he think
he's going to
do just like the good old days yeah you
on the sidelines while I do all the
work he's a boss and bosses give
orders but they took a run at us in
Broad day
like they're getting
desperate guys got good instincts guys
got I get
everything surveillance photos don't do
you
[Music]
justice looks like you had a rough night
had
worse need a new jacket what's wrong
with the one you just bought it has
blood on
[Music]
it